I thought we talked about the laws of
thermodynamics and maybe the second law
in particular so there are four laws
there are laws 1 2 3 and then this law 0
which I suspect was slotted in after the
first 3 laws and it's actually sort of
in some sense also the most trivial of
them which is why it's probably called
the zeroth law so the zeroth law just
basically says if you've got three
bodies call them a B and C if a and B
are in thermal equilibrium with each
other which is just a fancy way of
saying they're the same temperature
which means if you put them together no
heat flows from one to the other so if a
and B are in thermal iquilibrium and if
a and C are in thermal equilibrium then
B and C will be in thermal equilibrium
it does seem fairly obvious it's it's a
kind of a formal way of saying really
there is only one definition of
temperature and that there is no way you
can actually come up with a system where
temperature is defined in a funny way
such that one of these bodies has some
peculiar property such that its
temperature as far as body a is
concerned is one thing but its
temperature as far as what you see is
concerned is another thing and I think
because it is sort of stating the
obvious I think that's why it's a zeroth
law so the first law is also fairly
obvious in that it's basically sort of
Restatement of the conservation of
energy in thermodynamics there's kind of
two sorts of energy that useful energy
which is work so that's when you if you
push something whatever that's that's
sort of applying energy to it and that's
useful energy and then the useless
energy which is heat
and what the service law says is that if
you've got a body and you apply a
certain amount of work to it so that's
one sort of energy and then you add a
certain amount of heat to it the total
energy of that body will be whatever it
was to start with plus the energy you
added from the work plus the energy you
added from the heat so it's really just
a statement of the conservation of
energy really so I mean there are kind
of obvious laws but you have to start
with the basic building blocks in order
to build up the entire subject to
certain thermodynamics and these are
really the most fundamental building
blocks the third is difficult to talk
about until we introduce a concept of a
thing called entropy which is to do with
the disorder of a system and the third
law is basically saying that as you cool
a system down towards absolute zero the
degree of disorder so this quantity
entropy drops towards zero already stops
to a very low value so classically it'll
drop to zero there are some sorts of
systems it'll just drop to a low value
but it will decrease until you get to
Absolute Zero and there will stop so
second law has as various formulations
the first formulations were put together
really before this idea of entropy and
disorder was invented and they were very
kind of operational definitions of it so
there are two classical statements of
the second law of thermodynamics the
first is one due to a guy called
classiest who said that heat won't
travel from our cold body to a hot body
and that's sort of trivially known if
you've just got a hot body and a cold
body and you put them in contact with
each other the heat will flow from the
hot things or the cold thing so they'll
end up at the same temperature they'll
meet somewhere in the middle and so it's
kind of obvious if you're just doing you
know putting things in contact with each
other but his statement is stronger than
that which is there is nothing you can
do to make heat flow from a cold body to
a hot body without putting some work in
so if you're prepared to inject some
energy you can make hot things colder
and colder and so if you know a fridge
is an example where you pump heat after
something which is already cold and add
it to the air which is warmer so fridges
you know in some sense they violate the
purist view of this view but this law
that you can't get eat trouble for
something cold something hot but they'll
get out is but you're putting work into
you're allowed to
it so if you've just got an isolated
system you can't do it it's a one-way
street and there's no way around it it's
the important point that no matter how
clever a machine you come up with you
could never make it so it will extract
the heat from the colder thing and add
it to the hotter thing without having to
put some work in along the way so that
was Klaus elusive statement and then
there's the other statement and that's
that's in sometimes that's a sort of
physicists statement because that's
about you know heat flow and
observations of what happens when you
put bodies in contact with each other
but the second version of this is due to
Lord Kelvin and Kelvin statement is more
of an engineer state this comes back to
this fact that there are these two sorts
of energy that's kind of useful energy
you can do work with and this useless
energy heat that you can't really do
work with directly and Kelvin statement
basically says that you can't turn heat
directly into work you can't just take
heat and turn it into into useful energy
now of course again you do this as steam
engine for example takes heat and turns
it into work but in order to do that you
have to have waste heat left over so his
statement is that you can't again have a
kind of fuel box where you just put
heating at the top and the only thing
that comes out is work you're always
going to have to have heat going in work
coming out but then some waste heat
coming out as well there is a
fundamental limit as to how little the
amount of waste heat there is that you
can get out of it and you can figure out
what that limit is but but it's always a
finite amount you can't you can never
reduce that to some you know in
completely an infinitesimal zero level
those two things sound like completely
different statements like they're
talking about completely different
things but it turns out they're exactly
equivalent to one molar and I can show
you if you like so what we're going to
do this is by saying if one of these
versions of the second law isn't true
then the other one isn't true either so
let's assume that's violate Klaus uses
statement of the second law which
specially says you can't get heat to
flow from the cold body to the hot blade
so let's assume we have a magic fridge
which violates that law by actually
allowing us to suck energy out of the
cold body put it into the hot body
without actually having to plug the
fridge into the mains okay and then over
here I'm going to just have a engine
like a steam engine or something that
which doesn't violate any of the laws at
all and I'm going to take an amount of
energy out of this hot body you two and
because this isn't breaking any laws
there has to be some waste heat from it
so we're
set it up so that amount of weight he is
actually with q1 she's been loyal and
happy so they yes exactly that's not
violating any of the laws and we're
going to get some work out of this which
is just the difference between those two
this is the first law again that says
that you have to conserve energy overall
so if we've got q2 flowing in and stay
in the amount of work we get out of
there which is the difference between
the two now the neat part here is that
what we've managed effectively to do if
I just draw a box around this there's a
lot here and so that's just going to be
I'm going to stick all that on in a box
and I'm not going to care what's inside
that box and what that box is actually
doing is it's taking an amount of energy
well how much energy is coming in it's
taking heat out of this body and taking
an amount well q2 flowing out and choose
one flowing back in so the amount of
energy that's coming out of the top body
is q2 minus q1 and this box and the only
thing that's coming out of it is work to
2 minus q1 so this now violates kelvins
version of the second law because
actually with what we've always done in
this process is we've taken an amount of
heat out of the top body and turn it
directly into work and kelvins latent of
the law says you can't do that
so that shouldn't be a surprise because
we fill the box by breaking the rules we
just wrote quote is wording of the rules
exactly but what we're trying to show is
that those two statements of the second
law are the same as each other they
really stating the same law and so
indeed if they are the same law you'd
expect if you broke one version of the
law you'd break the other version of the
laws as well but if there are actually
different laws or the stating different
things and that wouldn't necessarily be
the case but that's kind of halfway
there that shows that if we violate
classicist version then we're violating
kelvins version but to really show their
equivalent we've also got the show if we
violate kelvins version we're also
violating cloudiest assertion care okay
so kelvins version of the law says that
you can't just turn energy into work so
you can't just take heat and turn it
directly into work that has to be a
byproduct
so let's violate that by coming up with
a magical engine which directly turns
energy turns heat into work an engine
which yet which does nothing but take
this useless energy heat and turn it
directly is useful energy work and
infinitely efficient steam engine so a
real steam engine would be waste heat
coming out of the
but we're violating kelvins law here so
we don't have to do that okay okay and
then we're going to take that work and
we're going to use it to power a fridge
and that fridge will because this is now
a proper fridge it's not violating class
EEOC's law or anything we can get it to
work so we plugged it into the mains and
we can actually had use it to suck
energy q2 out so we can figure out how
much heats get to come out the other end
it's just going to be the two lots of
energy going in there's Q 1 and Q 2 so
now if we just put a box around all this
lock and say this is this is now my
magic machine and I don't really want to
look inside the box I just want to know
what it's doing what's happening it's
sucking an amount of energy Q 2 out of
the cold and then on the hot side you've
got q1 coming out on q1 plus q2 going in
so the net amount of energy flowing into
the hot is q2 so effectively we created
a machine here where with nothing you
know no export external wires or
anything within that box
it takes in any amounts of heat q2 from
a cold body and adds it to a hot body
and that violates klaus is his version
of a second law so we've shown is that
if kelvins versions of the second law
isn't true then cloudy situation isn't
true and it's a cloud uses version ii or
isn't true then killed intuition the
second law isn't true and so I just kind
of finish it off so we've got these two
laws kelvins version and classiest
assertion and the sort of four
possibilities they might both not be
true one might be true and the other one
might be false or the other way around
or they both might be true and what
we've ruled out by showing this is we've
shown that if kill wins laws of is false
thing then Claudius's has to be false to
true if clouds this is version of the
law is false then kelvins can't be true
test to be false as well so we ruled out
those two in the middle so the only two
possibilities is they're either both
wrong or they're both right and that's
just another way of saying that they're
saying exactly the same thing we haven't
been able to prove that they're true but
we've shown that if they with one of
them is true the others true and it's
one of those folks the other ones folks
in other words they're kind of
equivalent to each other
signed up which will keep it in an orbit
basically following following the earth
around there used to be lots of science
fiction stories about l-3 used to be a
popular place to put the anti earth or
you know if you're an evil genius that's
where you put your hidden lair